links alfredo häberli renommierter
schweizer produktdesigner rechts martin
grunwald europas einziger professor für
taktik oberfläche sind ein teil unserer
umwelt unsere dreidimensionalen umwelt
und insofern haben wir zu den
verschiedensten oberflächen auch eine
verschiedene ja auch emotionale
beziehung wenn ich dachte dann wenig
biss um eine zahlung fällig
willkommen in den heiligen hallen der
haptik an der universität leipzig geht
martin grunwald seiner leidenschaft nach
seine passion gehört dem haptischen dem
tastenden begreifen von objekten und
dinge der tastsinn forscher misst die
reaktionen seiner probanden wenn sie
bestimmte gegenstände in die hand nehmen
wie er das genau macht bleibt sein
geheimnis
das grundprinzip unserer analytik
besteht darin dass wir finger bewegungen
während der bedienung benutzung von
etwas in sozusagen in mikroskopisch
kleinen bereich analysieren und messen
die menschliche finger gruppe nimmt
unterschiede ab einem tausendstel
millimeter war schon bald unterstützt
mit seinem wissen produktgestalter bei
der entwicklung denn zwei drittel aller
kaufentscheide werden mit dem tastsinn
gefällt sogar im buchhandel
man kann natürlich durch raffinierte
oberflächen veränderungen erhebungen
glatt halten rauigkeit und das mit
nutzen um sein werk dann besser zu
verkaufen
fabrik besuch im aargauischen klingler
der designer alfredo häberli arbeitet
gerade eine neue kollektion von sesseln
und sofas
er wird als garant für helvetische
gestaltungsqualität museum widmen ihm
ganze ausstellungen und den
eidgenössischen design preis für das
lebenswerk hat auch schon im sack
seine idee hier eine tierhaut ein
möbelstück das material definiert den
entwurf napoli setzt auf nachhaltigkeit
und mehr sinnlichkeit berücksichtigt
wenn ich hoffen so falle oder sitze dann
dann ist das eigentlich dachte ich okay
vor der ergonomie als vor der wichtigste
moment und um punkt das ist sozusagen
einen moment auch von von haptik design
sozusagen bei ansonsten funktional kaum
unterscheidbaren produkten merkmale
bereitzustellen die über das tastsinns
system als was besonderes wahrgenommen
werden und gerade der luxusgüter bereich
lebt auch vom haptik design bei den
alltäglichen gegenständen zeigt sich wir
leben im zeitalter der glätte ein graus
für optiker grunwald wir tasten nicht
mehr wir streichen nur noch warum
eigentlich dominiert die glätte in der
welt der dinge
vielleicht gibt es auch so eine
kulturgeschichtliche material
entwicklung dass man einfach mit dem mit
dem glatt heizkraft kommentiert wie man
sozusagen material manipulation
beherrscht
je glatter um so kompetent
handschmeichler sollen sie sein die
objekte von alfredo häberli den tastsinn
betören er versteht sich auch als
botschafter neuer materialien und sagt
seinen kreationen wolle er eine seele
verpassen und die mache die hektik aus
nicht die optik ist sicher dass
visuelles allerwichtigste wenn man gut
daran alle auf und biss gesät ob er dann
drück bestätigung wo dann das zynisch
oder weichheit oder oder hertie das ist
genauso wichtig und man darf das ja noch
unterschätzt